there is someone in our vffs today
who is all about the good and taking
care of people
our vff ricky smith was
oh hi ricky hey wait can we can we be
friends
oh i'm usually the one asking that can
we stay in touch can we be friends yes
ricky yes okay because i like to dance i
know you're a dancer i like to dance
that's like my thing i'm a dance guy so
energy
oh ricky i love everything about you and
now this new information about
friendship and dancing yes yes yes okay
so i was so excited to talk to you today
because your organization called random
acts of kindness
everywhere and i do love the everywhere
um because it feels blanketed and
ubiquitous
like it's possible all around rather
than
yes ubiquitous everywhere
i know i mean it's like i didn't go to
school
so i studied the dictionary because it's
available and free
um and uh but you that's what you're
doing
is sometimes you know things feel very
targeted
and where we see good we wonder about
the rest
of the world and how that's going to get
taken care of so i do think everywhere
is a powerful word to attach to the
random acts of kindness
and it feels very hopeful and very
actionable and
i just want to know what was your
inspiration behind starting your
movement
yeah so it's funny that you started off
with the whole friendship thing
um i was down and out i moved to l.a was
going through a pretty
rough divorce and no one knew i was
struggling um
emotionally you know mentally uh
financially
and i had 20 bucks left in my name and
i was like you know what i'm gonna just
go back to cleveland ohio where i'm from
and just try to figure things out and i
said you know what i'm gonna take this
20 bucks
i want to buy pizza for homeless people
um i went and bought four pizzas
and with their permission we we sat down
and you know i didn't talk about their
homelessness i didn't talk about their
struggles they didn't talk about my
struggles
and we just simply just bonded just
eating pizza i joked that
you can't eat pizza mad like who eats
pizza upset
and um i posted it with their permission
having a pizza party my friends
and it kind of went viral people started
doing in other cities um that same day
and um i was like you know what this
energy and this good feeling
i got to keep it going it's been eight
years of me just being the guy that just
tries to bring a little uh happiness to
the world
and it's working like your tentacles are
reaching out and enveloping
people i mean that is the response like
when you throw these pizza parties it
inspires
other people to do it have you been
surprised by that or
yeah i have it to be honest with you
it's just the energy to me is like
the feeling you get and you said it best
during these times literally like we're
all in this together
and we're all going through something it
it rings more now true than ever
because we literally are going through
something so who doesn't want to be
surprised with it with a free pizza
right
or just a pizza or a community because
you're all in this together so
i tell you all the time that you know
instead of taking 20 selfies
take 19 but if you show yourself doing
good you might think it's bragging but
it motivates
inspires other people i'm literally
talking to my new best friend
by way of social media so it's like that
energy that spirit
because people don't realize too it's
not just a person receiving it
you also feel good doing it it just
makes you feel like
you're connected people think of you
know charity as being this thing you
have to be rich you have to be famous
now like you can literally just do what
you want to do in your corner your area
whatever
to try to make the world a better place
i also think people
are sometimes a little overwhelmed by
all that there is to do in the world
and so when they see something that is
doable
or the idea and light bulb or the place
to go
to do something doable you've created
that
and there's a you know and
a familiar non-overwhelming
approach to what you're doing and yet it
is huge and powerful
and we just love what you are doing and
we wanted to help you spread
um that love in your community and
kindness so
we actually reached out to our friends
of angelos of
lakewood and they're gonna give you free
pizza for an
entire year to help with your homeless
pizza party whoa
and now that we are new best friends i'm
gonna put this on my website at the show
at the
i'm going to put it on my instagram and
we're going to do everything we can
to help facilitate bring awareness and
shine a light on what you are already
doing thank you ricky thank you so much
thank you honestly thank you from the
bottom of my heart
my supporters my followers are all huge
fans
so shout out to them nationwide they
literally love you more than you know
you they they you
you are a part of rake right next to god
is over so welcome to the crew
thank you i'm honored to be a part of it
and i can't wait to promote
it and support thank you ricky thank you
so much